hi hello everyone welcome to our
september meetup
for those here from hamburg moyne
and before we get started and this is
very important we are going to record
this session and we are going to publish
it on pi data's youtube channel
so in case you wouldn't like uh to have
your name
or your image in the internet so just
just make sure that you turn off your
camera or you re
your rename yourself also if you would
like to ask
questions be mindful that your voice may
be on the internet so
if you prefer you can just also uh ask
write your questions on the chat
if you have any questions uh please just
raise your hand
and one of our moderators will unmute
you
you are also very welcome to just uh
write on the chat and we are going to
take the questions to the
speakers uh
your hosts for tonight's meet that my
name is camila i'm an i.t consultant at
buyer's darf
we are also here with yumin yeah uh
my name is view me and i am a junior
data scientist
i am very new as an organizer for pi
data handbook
and it's very nice to have everyone here
tonight and also with us
is christian hi i'm christian
i also do data science and i do it as a
freelance in the last four years
pi data really helped me get started
back then and i'm still learning a lot
so
hi and welcome everyone
and if you're not familiar so
pi data is a global community for
developers and users of open source data
tools
and it's originally an educational
program of non-focus a non-profit based
in the u.s
and if you are curious you can also
follow us on twitter
at uh pi data hamburg you also have here
uh five data channels and so on and this
talk is going to be available later on
in our channels
and also at pi data tv
very important we are a community that
we love uh
participation we love to involve
everyone so
and open source is about participation
we are
always looking for speakers so
if you are building anything interesting
with open source data tools speak about
it
especially if you are part of
underrepresented
group or a first time uh by data
speakers
could be that you are a little bit shy
and say you know i'm working on
something fantastic here but i'm just
too shy to make a presentation
don't worry we can help you so just
reach out to any of the organizers
we can help you coach you prepare
presentation and everything that you are
able to come here and give this
presentation so
just get in contact also we are looking
for volunteers so
and it's basically about meetup planning
speaking speaker outreach and support
and of course sponsors to host a meetup
now that we are in convict 19th time
it's a little bit
uh not clear how we're moving forward to
that but as soon as we are able to host
on-site meetups then of course sponsors
are more than welcome
and um to introduce the agenda today
first we'll start with talk by shock
ting
hall she will explain to us why ai
industry needs a revision control graph
database
and afterwards we will have a break for
10 minutes
and followed by the second talk by lice
and christian maybe can take over from
there
yeah i've been really looking forward to
the second talk by
lies especially from my work experience
in data science
building software is hard but the field
of software engineering
has some best practices and tools get us
covered got some experience
but building data stuff is another
quality i
think i always feel like we lack some
best practices and
tool support to keep complexity in check
so
i'm really looking forward to this one
liz is going to introduce us to kidro
and i'm
curious to see if that's the key
and if anyone have any questions during
the talk please do not hesitate to put
the question
in the chat or you can also raise up
your hand if you want to ask the speaker
directly
so maybe now we hand it over to shock to
tell us why ai industry needs a revision
control graph database
yeah sure so first of all i think let me
try to share my screen first
and um okay
uh for the host i think i am going to
take over
because there was a warning saying that
i would take over which i am doing it
right now
um so uh yeah why ai
industry needs a revision control graph
database
because i think you know most people
here are actually working in data
science working in data
so actually ai are powered by data i
think this is like
i don't have to explain that if you work
with data you know that actually ai is
just a buzzword
everything is just you know kind of
you know calculations based on data so
there's no magic here
um so to deal with all these data why do
we need a database that is
actually reliable can let you work
smoothly so i will explain a little bit
about that
today um so for those of you who really
love slice i have a link to the slide
back there i
put all these slides on slice.com so if
you want you can take a picture of this
slice and
you can you know have to slice
afterwards if you'd like and also you'll
get my contact information so if you
have questions
in the future you want to ask me feel
free to contact me through twitter
my inbox is open so
um so i'm chuck um so yeah that's a
cartoon version of me
there and also uh i love open source so
i work in open source project
uh before you know i have some projects
that i initiated their projects that i
joined to help my friends and all this
right now i'm so lucky that i work full
time
for a open source graph database it's
terminusdb
and it's not just graph database it's
also do something like git so wow it's
like
it sounds amazing so what it is um
and uh before i tell you about that i
also organized a lot of um
different events uh including you know
um
euro python which uh will happen you
know
next year i would be helping out as well
and also paid the global tickets
on sale it will be in november so please
join that's the first
online phi data conference and also i
organize
other online conferences as well in
december it's called pyjamascon
it's super cozy so uh yeah so talk to me
if you want to know any of those
so i also stream on twitch so if you
want to see me more you can find me
there i stream
every week so um yeah and
so first of all what is the graph and
why do we need graphs right so
i think most of us are very comfortable
with csv we use pandas data frame we do
all this all the time
i was working as a data scientist before
i know the deal
right because like it's you know it's
like the golden standard you load in all
this
you know your file from like you know
from csv or from excel into you know
pandas data frame they're all
or sometimes you just load them in you
know something like mysql
you know some sql database right so
you're just using you know some
join and select another stuff and work
with data so
but you know i discovered like using
graph actually is quite amazing so
for example here now we have we have
this
actually we have some history about how
it evolves so
um this is actually at the beginning you
know we're all familiar with
this here right kind of in the middle we
have all these sql database
the things that we call them relational
database and things are actually you
know
stored in a tablet format you know and
sometimes you can make some joints and
relations using the keys and stuff so
uh i think you must have like some
experience with uh mongol
uh you know and you know some you know
postgrad all this stuff
um and then some of you a smaller
section of you may have tried neo4j so
what is neo4j neo4j is
kind of more or less like the first open
source graph database one of the first
one that like they started years ago i
think more than 10 years ago
and then they actually they built
something called property graph
okay so things are like actually built
with again
with relations but instead of the table
relations actually they're different
objects they have different relations
together so they're actually like
for one object you have different
properties okay
but that's actually only one form of
graph because for
for proper graph you can actually have
things more complicated than that
so that's why later there will be like
some new technologies coming up there
like
graph database that actually is based on
ldf so you have a more flexible schema
to describe how things are related to
each other it's not just one thing with
properties
you can declare like things that you
know some things the child of
some parents and so relations can be
more complicated
and also you can maybe like you know fix
the catenarity of some
objects like you know you can't have two
property at the same time or things like
that
more more complicated and then the
latest thing that we have is terminus db
so it's our database so compared to
you know d graph and neo4j is even more
flexible because we use type system
so you can even uh declare the type
of your object so in terms db would have
data type object which is things that
you are familiar with
strings integer or negative integer um
decimal you know even days time and all
these things
or integer range you know it could be a
more complex data format
um kind of like the d type in in pandas
but also you can have object type
property so you can have
kind of like the class in python so you
can have the class and then you have the
instance of the class so things like
that
can happen with an owl defined database
like terminusdp
so it's a little bit like
knowledge heavy but if you have
questions you can ask me
anytime so i hope that's okay so
a using graph actually is much easier to
interpret the model and
understand like how the real world is
represented
because our world like our data is not
always in a tablet format
a table format actually takes you know
take some processing to actually
represent what's going on
uh i think you know the most uh you know
most straightforward example is like
this right
so you have all these bunch of people
you have some of the information
and then here i don't know like how many
of you have figured out what this is
actually so you can type in the chat or
you can shout out i don't know whether
you can
speak or not but you know i hope you
figure it out
i give you like maybe two seconds um
so yeah this is actually i can see some
chats coming in so some of you may
already got it so um
actually it's a family tree right so
before that you can see that actually
you have to make a mental map
of like actually mother and father
actually they are the
key the link to this person's id
so it's you know you have to process it
it's not like if you have presented this
boom
and just like very straightforward john
relations with
john cena father and son okay so also
you can color code it
the gender as well so because mother
always female well biologically so you
have to
you know mary is john's mother and then
you know uh john cena so like you can
color coded it so you can put all these
properties uh you know kind of in the
graph as well
so not just the relation so everything
is very straightforward you just look at
it you know what it is
okay so uh so yeah like a word is
complicated but
you know presenting in a graph actually
is more flexible than presenting it in
tables
um so this is sql i hope you're familiar
with it
i don't like it when i was working in a
data scientist i really i swear i hated
it
i was like you know i don't like writing
thousands lines of code just like doing
you know grabbing a table
you know just something very simple you
grab a table you aggregate it and join
it back to yourself again and then you
join to something else and you aggregate
and uh oh it's a big mess
it's really like you have to it's very
difficult to debug as well you really
like pull your hair out
and you can see what this is doing like
i don't understand what this
is doing oh but actually what this is
doing is to find the mother and the
grandmother i think
maternal grandmother actually of john so
this is another way of doing it
this is when you start everything in a
graph so this is an example of
the mca query in terms db so we have
something called
waco which is a query language that we
invented
uh there are two way of uh writing it so
this is kind of like a
javascript format the python format is
actually exactly the same some of the
name may change because
in python you can't use n so we change
it to what co n and things like that but
the structures are the same so you would
have some variables with the v
there these are the links so instead of
having a key
you know to join things together join
the whole table together we actually
make variables to link things
so this is more straightforward for
programmers because well we use variable
all the time
and then you can see that we have we
will have mother id and then mother's
mother
so that's grandmother id so you would
have all this information presented to
you
back with like what is the possibility
of this variable so this is actually
like kind of like logic
well the reason being because terminus
dp is built with prolog
so for those of you who know prolog
actually is a
is a logical program right so everything
is space
based on logic so basically when you
make a query it's making a logic
and this is how you create you know you
make a query and this is more
straightforward it
makes sense in our brain rather than
joining tables
for me at least i don't know whether you
agree or not you can tell me afterwards
so also you can store data simatically
so like i said you can store the
property of the data there you can store
a data type
so no more like messy things you know
when you read things from csv
you know sometimes strings that cost
this number numbers that cost a string
it really like
you really hated it because some ids you
know if someone made a mistake and
caused it
as a number then like all the the you
know the the zeros in front will be gone
and then like everything just messed up
and you hated it you know you have to
patch that again and
stuff um so if you store the data type
with your data you know no more mess
around
so the so it's already sitting there so
the schema basically tell you
what you can do with the data what you
can't do with the data so that's really
more secure
and more you know more uh error proof
so that's much better i would say um
so yeah uh maybe we could talk a little
bit about like uh
our graphs because that's something
quite new like
i guess like before that i have never
know like what was that
i have to google like what what is owl
mean
because like it means like uh some web
ontology language
things like that so um so actually it's
very powerful for
data modeling like i said because uh
well everything is described in triple
and all these relations are actually
all flexible they are like relations
that you could define
uh what they are and then for example
for properties you can define what
properties domain so which means that
what this property belongs to
so for example me and my age so h would
be a property with the domain
like person like me and then the range
would be it's a number so it would be a
data type of integer let's say
and actually not negative in the journal
but it can be like minus seven years old
or things like that
um so yeah so it's strongly type
and you know there's again no mess up or
anything but it's flexible enough that
you could declare anything
in the schema so it also supports a plus
you can inherit something so that's
useful when you have really complicated
structure
we have actually a historical graph that
things are quite you know if you have
all the human history and you have
things that is you know subclass of
something because there's always you
know
a sub subset of the study or something
then like
this is really helpful um
so uh another advantage is that we can
store data like
it so uh the reason why we could do that
because everything is a graph
and then basically if you have try
you know if you have tried like kind of
visualize what your git commits are like
it's actually like a graph because all
your commits are actually linked to each
other and then when you
whenever you branch and merge and rebase
and all this stuff
actually are moving all these relations
with the graph
so um so when we represent things in a
graph
we could you know we actually we store
the database in the graph format as well
uh my colleague has a very scary slide
of like how
these branching emerging are stored like
in a graph format
and i don't put it there because it's
too scary i don't want to scare you with
that detail but
our very smart engineer like got big
like how you can store things in a graph
format that lets you do all these
branching and merging and crazy stuff
so i i will talk a little bit about that
but i i won't scare you trust me
um so the advantage of doing that is
that
you you won't you won't do this again
you know some of us may have done this
before that when we passed a long day
even when we have a shared drive right
you could be like okay i have i want to
do some experiment
i you know process the data and then i
create a model oh i don't like it maybe
the data i need to clean it up a little
bit
i create another data set put it in that
model i don't like it maybe the model is
the parameter is not right and i
change it and then you know and then you
have different versions of different
things
it's lace can tell you later that like
actually this is also a problem that
casual is solving so
it's a little bit of spoiler of the next
talk but
you know so this is actually a big mess
everybody is trying to solve this
problem
everybody wants a more smooth uh
flow of collaboration and also more
you know when you manage data especially
that you don't want to be like
there are multiple versions of data that
you don't know you know
which one to use like which one is the
latest all these big mess things you you
want to avoid those
um so well like i said because it's
graph then
if you store everything in a graph then
you can store it like a git format so
you can do git
um so but the thing is like why don't i
just
use git to do it i can just put things
on github github first of all it doesn't
let you to store a lot of data
and also it's good for code because git
is storing
data like if you see your um get uh
changes uh git diff so actually it
compare things line by line
so it knows it's not always the case
with data like i said if you store
things like a graph that you know
things are in triple so sometimes if you
compare things line by line it doesn't
really tell you what's the difference
and all these things so git is designed
for for code
actually because you would change some
line of code and all this stuff so
yeah it's not perfect for data so we
need some other thing that's like
it but for data so yeah so
we store data in a kind of a sustained
data format
so it's slowing layers it optimized the
efficiency
so you can see here a little bit that
when you make it
first of all like you have an initial
you know playing so
every every query actually like update
query we call that
it's actually like a plane so it's a
commit so when you
actually for example each plane it will
get the red and the green so that's like
adding some triple there and deleting
some triple there
so you can see that every time you make
a commit you add two layers there so
what is deleted what is added
so you add there and then you can add
more so everything is kind of like get
in store
well if you're a git guru you would kind
of
you know argue with me that oh no git
doesn't store this well we do
because it's actually easier for us to
store there so
it's slightly different but the compete
and all these kind of ideas are all the
same
um so it's it's much better
um to just to store data that way and
because we use that sustained data
structure everything is super complex
i didn't put too much detail about
sustained data structure here
if you're interested you can ask me
basically we just you know kind of like
zipping everything very compact together
so we are lightweight
uh so everything even though everything
is in memory you know
well we love in-memory because it's fast
and all this stuff you know python is in
memory as well
uh pandas all this but uh you know
you're worried that oh maybe
it's easily blowing up my ram then don't
worry we kind of
try to come compact everything as much
as possible
and of course if you need you know
bigger storage
there's also other solutions that's
available as well our storage is
optimized so
you know the fastest fastest thing is
in-memory but also
we have some store that actually is not
in memory so stored there
forever if you don't delete it um
so uh also you can uh now
this is just coming up this this month
actually is the we have
the the hub so it's like github but it's
for graph database
uh i will show you a little bit
afterwards and um
so that you can actually do easily do
data ops you can actually
do things like it you can collaborate
you can clone your data you can
publish your data there uh it's good
especially when you have some
open data that for example we are now
actually working on putting some kind of
creative common data
that's on hub so everybody can just
clone it and
you know do experiment with it and do
some you know data
analysts with it um you could also
probably
if you're like if you're a researcher if
you are happy to publish your data
then you could actually publish there as
well so uh yeah so it's free to register
uh we do have some pro
tier that is you know that's pay but
everybody can start using it for free we
won't charge you unless you want to go
to pro right we won't we won't force you
to
to to pay after a few times no it could
be free forever if you just want to use
it
for open data it's like it right if
everything is open then we won't charge
you
um so there are some limit on the
private data how much you can have there
as well
so yeah so no harm signing up i guess
and
um so i think that's time for that more
so less time
travel so i don't know how much time do
i still have so maybe i i would keep an
eye on the clock
so if you have around 20 minutes i guess
15 20 minutes
uh yeah so uh
so first of all uh you can see this is
the the
terminus db when it runs on your browser
so
actually right now we do have a electron
app for window users
i am using mac so i'm still using the
docker image
so it run on my browser here um
and you can see i've got lots of things
because i've been using it myself as
well doing some experiment
um but what i want to show you is that
we could clone
data from hub so i have already signed
in with hub so you can see this is me my
profile here
so uh you can create an account if you
haven't logged in you just need to you
know logged in and you know
create an account and other stuff and
you could put your picture here just
like github
and um so uh when you logged in you
could actually click on clone and then
you would have all these
uh public available data set that you
could clone so
um one other thing that we got to play
around today is to play with this
bank data example so this is a very
simple data set
it's meant for people just to play so
they're actually something more serious
as well i can show you
actually go back and i'll show you we
have the
you know the dbpedia so if you don't
know dbpd is actually a uh
database version of wikipedia so
there's lots of data there so be careful
when you click clone it would take a
while for it to be
to be cloned to your local machine and
also it will cause some space as well
um and also such a global data bank so
this is
a project that we're working on with the
historians we want to
you know store a lot of human history in
there so if you're doing some
history research then this is the place
you could go
uh the others mainly are for you know um
tutorial and demonstration purposes you
you'll feel free to
you know this is a more lightweight and
more kind of like
playground for you to try things out so
we have already got the bank data so
let's go back to home
and then we already have the bank data
example that's cloned
to our machine oh actually what i want
to do so let me go back and delete it
because i want to show something
else so yeah you can delete it just by
you know typing in the name here
that's okay so let's do it again so this
time instead of just cloning
uh i could actually ever click on it
i could actually fork it as well so it's
kind of like github that you could fork
a copy of it
and you have one in your account i think
and then
let's see and then if i click on my
databases
oh it's not cloning for some reason
nevermind we can just like
download it and play around just that we
can't uh
we can't push it back to hot because uh
the the owner is gavin my colleagues or
i can't i can't really push it
because he hasn't given me the uh allow
you know
uh authorization to push to mess with
his data so
but that's okay so let's have a play so
what is
in this bank data i hope this is big
enough for you to see let me zoom in a
little bit
so i hope this is big enough for those
of you who may
watching this on an ipad or something
so we have free person here so like i
said this is a
sandbox so this is very simple it's a
free person
they have a bank account and this bank
account if you click
on schema here so you know every account
we would have properties so bank account
we have property of who is the owner and
then what is the balance here
so this is how is this console is a very
nice place that you can explore
some like graph properties and all this
stuff you can see all this you know
kind of metadata here um but if you're
trying to do something you can use
queries so if you're a data analyst
data scientist you could make query here
so now we only support javascript
on console but i will show you jupiter
notebook in a bit so if you want to use
python
of course you prefer python i assume
that's why you're here uh i will show
you how to do in python but i will show
a little bit of
how to do it in this console first okay
so for example we have uh jim here right
so
uh so let's check how much money jim has
okay so let me copy his id
and i'm doing something like i feel like
i'm a criminal here so
so yeah i think i'm okay to just do this
so jim
and then uh scm so actually
okay let me copy this because uh so yeah
because you have to really look at
so yeah you have this scm balance this
is the property so we want to check this
property right how much balance
jim has so let me go back here and then
so at
cm balance
yeah i hope you can see this this is
like the thing is not very you know
like people like me doesn't have good
eyesight we have problems seeing this so
um
yeah i have to tell my colleague to make
this like maybe
with much contrast with the background
so balance and then we want to know the
amount so
i type b here v represent this is a
variable so this is actually what we
would get from the result viewer so
i want to know the amount so i'm
declaring a variable amount here
so so i want to have gym balance
uh a n c e l
c okay balance as uh as a amount which
is
as the variable amount and give the
result back to me so
let me copy this first in case i ruined
okay
so i have amount so this is the variable
that we have
and the value is eight so jim has eight
i don't know pounds
let's say i mean uk's i assume that's
pounds
or euros maybe my colleagues in europe
so maybe eight euros okay so
jim has eight euros so oh yeah you're so
poor
so can we make jim rich so let's do this
so what i'm gonna do is i gotta do
something very naughty so i gotta do
an and query so in this end query those
two things
first of all i would delete what
jim has okay so delete jim's
amount and then i would be like adding
so
at triple oh actually i have to
do a query first uh because we have to
find this amount so
we know that he got h euros but imagine
if we don't know then we have to make a
query so we know that the amount is
h so i can this one will be replaced by
h so because
this is how variables work right so um
now i can make gym so it's the same
thing except
that this time they won't be amount it
would be let's say
9000 pounds euros so 9000 euros so jim
will get rich
so let's make jim rich
okay so this is the commit message it's
basically like your git commit you type
a commit message so i'm making jim rich
here i'm just making a remark to myself
so again i copy all this in case
something bad happened
i run it successfully updated so what
happened is that i go back to home
and then you see that now so before if
you have pay attention
like we have all this stuff that might
call it did you know like editing gym
all this stuff and now i have my commit
here make jim rich
so everybody who check this database
will know that i've done something with
jim right i make him rich
i don't know why i do that but well i've
done it
so um yeah so that's what happened so
now what i'm going to do is that i got
to show you ex
well similar things but done in a
jupiter notebook so
here undone uh oops
can i see it right oh sorry i i'm trying
to switch the tabs
okay this this zoom thing is kind of in
my way just one second
i don't know why this is the case okay
right so
um yeah so here this is uh the demo
is in jupyter notebook and so you can
use the python clients to do it so you
can just pip
install terminals db client so you would
have it and then you can do all this
stuff
um so well vocal view is
in beta is not published yet but
i will let you know afterwards so what
you do
is that you have to connect to your
server so right now if you have
pay attention to my address bar here
that i'm running it on a localhost which
is 127.0
and i'm running on porsche 6360 so i
think the default is 6363 but i've made
some changes so 636 over me uh you can
put yours here
or if you run it on a cloud instance you
just need to put it you know
the proper url um users i mean because
i'm running it locally so the default
user account everything is at mean okay
um the dbid this is the one the id that
we had
here that you know this is the id you
also need this to delete it
if you want to um yeah so and then
um you you use the client to connect to
the database
and then all you need is just you know
a id and accounts and key and all this
stuff so it will connect to the database
okay so i run this so import everything
i need is connected
right uh well actually it will print out
something but i i want to hide it from
from the jubilee lookbook output so i
just store it as stl but
if you don't mind output you can just
print it out
and then we will make a query so this is
similar to what we have done so this is
like well instead of
just finding gym this time i'll be like
find anybody
so be person variable person it could be
anyone anyone the balance and give me
the amount here
um i actually because this is because
it's python right so i
import the query as wq so it's wq.triple
instead of just triple
and then you have the code execute and
then put in the client here so this will
give you back the result
so if i run it will have a result i can
show you a little bit what is the result
actually so it will come back like
actually a json file
or a dictionary in this case in python
um
so it has a binding in there so this
binding is
basically contain all the results that
we have but this is ugly right this is
like nobody
like json nobody like this it's
difficult to see so
we actually provide something if you
have pandas then you could actually
install the pandas data frame extension
so you would have a method to change it
into a pandas data frame so now you can
see that mike jim and jane they have
13 and 9 000 for jim and you know jane
also got some money
um and this is okay so this is the thing
that i said is still in development so
this one
is actually not in the version that you
download from pip
yet but it will be soon so it's actually
a
interactive graph database this is d3
this is super cool
and what you could do with this is
actually you could also customize it for
example i want to
look i want the amount
to be with the color what color do you
like
maybe red i always like red is my
favorite color it's dangerous
and icon uh i can change the icon of it
i need a unique code
you need code uh to be
let's say what what should we use as the
icon let's put it as
a um let's see what do i have i want an
emoji
money let's put the money in there so uh
let me is it copied yeah money okay
so let's see okay so now oops
now we have i zoom in too much come on
come back here okay so
you can see that i have uh so some money
so you can see the free person and then
the free amount
here uh is still in development so you
can see that
well well it would be great if i can
show the amount instead of just the
money icon here but
we are still developing it so but it
will be there soon
um so yeah and the other thing is that
you can still do the branching and
merging on all this stuff
in python so here we will try to create
a hamburg
office so it's a hamburg branch so uh
what we'll do is just call
client.branch all this stuff are just
like you know fail safe right
in case it doesn't work then it will
give me some error and things like that
but all you need to run is just the
client.branch
and then you can switch now we have
switched to the hamburg office branch
and then what i got to do because like
oh we have created the branch sorry we
haven't checked out yet
so what we got to do is to check out
brunch and then
so check out the hamburg branch and then
add check there and then check out 100
euros let's say
i'm not that rich so yeah it seems that
it works so what
would happen is that we come back here
if we refresh
so here refreshing it
and then you would be able to see in a
second
that okay yeah so now branch
we have a pull down menu you can see
there's a hamburg office so this is the
main branch
you can see this is still make jim rich
this is what we have done
earlier but we can switch to hamburg
office
and now you can see that jerk is there
as well so
yeah so you can see check is here and
you can actually make a query to see how
much money sharecast
and oh it's not there or okay so let's
do it again
triple so doc check
scm balance
and then i want to know the amount
here and then
and run you see the checkup 100 euro
and actually you can see it in jupyter
notebook as well so if now if i go back
and run the query again
if i run this query again let's say okay
give me the triple give me the result
and all this stuff let's run it again
and now you can see that four person
because check is there as well so you
can see from the data frame check out
100 euros
so it's updated but it's only in the
hamburg branch what if we wanted so
let's say the you know at the end of the
day
every bank would just synchronize back
into the mink computer
or every 10 minutes it will just
synchronize into the main computer let's
say
so what we got to do is to merge it back
to the main branch
so now we're in hamburg office branch so
let's go to branch
you can create a new branch here as well
so like everything almost everything you
can do it either in
uh console with the you know uh user you
know the gui
or you can do it with python client but
you can do merge branch here
so you can see all this history make
dream rich this is the main branch
and this is the hamburg office it's one
commit ahead
yeah so uh what we're gonna do is that
we can merge into main
and then we're gonna say like update
back to
let's say and then we can merge so now
it's merged back to main so now if we
switch to
main branch and then check the commit
history again now editing check is there
so i'm now in a bank branch yay
so yeah this is all this crazy stuff
that you can do you can also do try and
travel here as well you can like roll
back and see what's happened this is
mick jambridge
so yeah it's not reflected there where
it's reflected on the timeline what's
happening you can check all this stuff
and yeah you can time travel to this
committee so like for example i want to
go back to
like i don't like chuck i don't i want
to ban her so you can go back
to time travel back to big dream bridge
so
i i think if you refresh that will go
back so i'm not sure i haven't tried
this part yet so
um yeah so what happened now
oh i'm still here okay so i'm there
forever you can't delete me
well actually you can delete me if you
make a query but um yeah so another
thing you could do is to synchronize um
so yeah really import uh you know you
can pull it
from clone again so kind of like you
know what you do with git pool you just
updated your local database with what
happening
uh in the you know in in remote
and you can push it back but of course
like i said because i cloned it from my
colleague's
database so i can't push it to to it
unless i have the permission so i'm i'm
not a collaborator for this data so i
can't push it
uh but you know for example i want to
pull main to hamburg office
or maybe i put main to main i pour it
and it should now be updated let's see
what's going on it's not updated let me
refresh to see what's going on
i've just pulled it back so maybe
because i am a head yeah maybe i'm a
head so i can't really pull it
uh back yeah so
yeah i wish i could demonstrate that if
i fork it but there's something there
that i'm not sure what happened
but basically i show you 90 of the
things that i want to show you which is
good
and let me go back to the slides then
so i think that's the end
it's a little bit shorter than the
schedule but we have more time for q a
which is good
and if you have other things that you
want to know more
visit our website we have documentation
there we also have blogs and a lot of
videos um
also on twitter there's also fun we
sometimes we just give our swags you
know like if you follow us
you would know that like my colleen may
post something like oh yeah just do some
easy things then we'll give you some
swags we'll post it to you
my colleague was like oh my god now i
have to go to the post office very often
because like giving all these people
swags
um and also we have a community on
discord discord is kind of like
slack but it's designed for gamers
there's cooler
there's more fun there you can chat with
people there you can have voice chat and
all these things
um so yeah join our community if you
have questions
the whole team is there my colleague
loves answering questions
so yeah i think that's it so
question time
okay thanks very much shock for the
nice introduction it's a very
interesting topic maybe i can start with
the tiny question
for example you showed us a
terminus db application on the bank
account example
and i'm also interested in for example
which industries or scenarios are
currently applying terminus to be
or which business cases do you find
especially suitable for using terminus
db
right so we actually we do have clients
right now at this stage even though it's
quite early we have a retail client
that basically the uh distributor of
goods
okay so they will have all these um
warehouses that they need a database to
manage it they want a solution that
is because they are quite massive in
ireland so they have a lot of different
inventory that they would want to have
better analysis on it so they could
you know uh analyze better when
the supplier will come you know to give
them stock and when they would could
you know fulfill the stock and all these
things so um yeah so there are actually
business use case uh well we are still
new we also have academic use case like
i said before we work with historians
about the history data uh we also
working kind of collaborating with for
example dbpdl like a lot of open source
data
at the moment so if you have any use
case like even if it's not commercial
then we're welcome to collaborate on
these things to
see how how it could work out and
um yeah of course like if you uh in
interested in a commercial way of course
get in touch and
our colleagues will basically give you
more information how we could help as
well
so and is
the bank balance also one of the real
application because we see that
the account holders they have amount of
money but there are no relation between
the account holders so how do graph
database help us here
in this scenario comparing to the
relational database
yeah that's very good question so um
right now we actually uh we may have
conversation with bangs all this but
like
there's of course this is just an
example it's just
as kind of sandbox it's not a real use
case okay
so that's why it's so simple it only got
like the amount and things
but uh here we showcase how we could
actually different
uh it's actually better to manage by you
know this git like feature that you
could have different branch
office and you could talk to each other
collaborate have a central database
so actually it's more secure because if
you know you
have a better it's like it right so if
you screw up if you make some mistake
you can always you know okay fix it by
time traveling back
you can uh rebase or pulling it again
from
from the main you know um so yeah so
we are just like kind of showcasing how
kind of a get like scenario applied to
database
could benefit uh something like if you
have data that
need to be you know sure that you you
you don't you don't need to have massive
backups you could if you have things
like it that you you could actually
have this security of not wearing
someone
accidentally deleting everything or mess
up your
your data so
yeah yeah and maybe one last question
from my side
um in the beginning you introduced that
well we can store data semantically with
a graphical database for example the
properties are
tied with the domain and also you
mentioned that git doesn't allow us to
store a lot of data
maybe you can quantify that a bit and
also i'm interested in
like how does the storage costs come
along with these additional benefits
so get actually uh if you uh kind of
there's a very good book
uh on git uh online actually it's a free
book it's
a pro git book it talks about how git
actually store things so git actually
store things they don't
actually get doesn't store diff so it's
like kind of controversial
to like to to the common beliefs that
get stole the dev because
git dev is so easy to see but no git
doesn't store
divs actually store your object uh you
know mainly
text objects in blobs or even binary of
course binary is also just
a bunch of data so installing blobs
which is a
optimized storage kind of solution
so if you look at your so if if you have
a git repo so if you look at your dot
git folder inside
you can see all this stuff right this
blob and also trees which actually is
like a graph
that store like how this commit are
related to each other how your file
structure is related to each other
so git and store things like with tree
and blob
so with us uh we because we want to
optimize for data
we still think first of all we starting
in triple so everything
uh also we store things in div so either
triple
added or triple are deleted okay so
everything is in triple
and also a sustained data structure is
just
means that we compare the difference so
we store the difference so that's
actually why it's more compact than
storing
everything so an example of it it would
be like for example a dictionary that
actually instead of storing every single
word so for each word i just saw like
maybe
the second word how the second was
different from the first word so for
example
um a chair and so air and chair right so
it's just that you know or oh it's not a
good example i do have a picture but i
forgot to put in the slice
so uh maybe pink and and then the next
word is pearl
so like the p are the common one so for
pearl it doesn't need to store the p
so just store o and then you just say
that okay we
grab the p from the the previous record
and then i just store the remainder of
it
so this is one example of the sustained
data structure so everything is more
compact
because it's still relative to the other
things
uh instead of storing every single
detail so um
yeah so that's more compact and triple
can also be benefit from this wave
because a lot of things are
duplicated you can see like for example
one thing can have different properties
so
you can see that this you know the
object of the triple would be duplicated
many many times so
uh storing things that way can actually
be more efficient uh
in in the so uh it could be more
lightweight actually
if you compare i think oh i forgot my
colleague do you have a comparison of
like
uh us and the other uh database actually
we are kind of quite compact compared to
the other databases
yep thank you very much and
if anyone else have any question please
feel free to type them
in the chat box i think we
will have a break in four minutes later
or we already passed the break time yeah
please i got one in the meantime
uh thanks for the great talk check i'd
would like you to talk a little bit more
about neo4j versus terpetus
neo4j has been around for 10 years now
and you're kind of the new
kid on the block um i'm planning to
build something on neo4j
should i consider this switch like how
would you make the
argument should we all switch
immediately who would you recommend this
to
well i would say that whether you're
building a very complex
schema definitely neo4j doesn't support
a very complex gamer for the reasons
i've explained that
for example if you have subset if you
have uh you want a
flexible like property that you can
control how many
like catenarity you have of that
property which means that like for
example this property can only happen
this is unique you can have multiple
property and all these things so neo4j
doesn't provide that kind of
uh more disk more kind of concrete
schema that you could pre-define before
you
you start and also you have to use cyber
uh with
neo4j so basically you are just like um
in if you use it with python right so
what i've seen people doing is that they
construct the string
as a query and then send it right so uh
but our python client is fully
uh you know talking with uh the back end
with uh well we basically the python
client
instead of constructing a string to pass
it to
the database would have a json a json ld
that will pass to the database so
in terms of security is is less
uh problems to injection attack you know
it's like
that's something of secret right you
have to check whether for example the
user can input something and then you
would insert it into your query string
that may be a chance that people could
have inject the text right so this is
well known in the data world
so if if passing is a json that's less
because this
format is straight right so it's json
it's just like dictionary
it's you it's you can't inject it just
like string because
you know you have key value key value
you can't really change it
so um yeah so it's uh it's
for that in that sense it's more secure
um
so yeah i think it really depends on
your use case whether it's if it's just
a very fun project this
security is not a big concern complexity
is not a big concern you can use neo4j
there's no problem and also like
something that will have to be fair
because something that neo4j because
they have a long history what they offer
uh something that we haven't offered yet
is for example some
analysis algorithm and all this stuff we
we are planning to go there in the
future but it's not there yet because
we're much younger so we
kind of provide all this like more uh
more core stuff first so um yeah so
those
if you need if those are important then
maybe you need to use neo4j
so yeah thank you um complexity and
security are definitely important for
what i'm trying to build so i have a
closer look at terminus
i wonder if there's more questions from
the chat from the audience
yep so yeah or
if you have questions afterwards like i
said my twitter is open
so you could actually i could go back to
the first slice
so you could have everything so you
could contact me
through uh twitter and oops oh i've
stopped sharing oh you have it there
great
yeah so you can uh you can contact me
for twitter and stuff like that so yeah
yeah thank you again um i love that the
two talks for tonight have this common
theme
of like taming the complexity that comes
in
because data is now first-class citizens
in our projects
just as important as code and
now i have the pleasure to give the
stage to lai slice cavalio
who is developer advocate at a company
called
quantum black
yes hello hello she's going to
introduce us to kate rowe and hopefully
also tell us the story about how keto
came to be open source i'm really
interested in that
oh cool i don't have that bit of my
slides but i can definitely tell you
that after all
absolutely well uh good evening everyone
uh let me just uh real quick here just
adjust my slides
um let me see
sorry
i am grabbing this the screen sharing
extracted
and are we all good can you all see me
perfect so uh wonderful
so good evening everyone um my name is
and i'm here today talking to you about
a little bit about kedron a little bit
about production code and a little bit
about
jupiter notebooks as well uh so
perfect so first of all who am i and why
am i here talking to you
uh my name is liz carvalho i'm a
developer advocate for quantum black
i've been working from home for this
last while
i am a last year student on i.t
almost there my background is civil
engineering
and environmental engineering as well
and i have a few years of experience
with the customer service
i've been working in qb for a few months
now so i joined the company in
june 2020 just squished in with kovid
was was very timely um scheduled it was
very good uh
then i also do a few things around uh
with volunteering
so i hosted the pi data dublin
summer season of 2020 uh i've been
working with python island as well
uh and i also helped hosting the euro
python
online edition for 2020.
um so the plan for today i'm gonna start
telling you a little bit about who we
are
in qb and what we do then i'm going to
show you a problem
i'm going to tell you a story uh then
i'm going to show you a solution
and we're going to go into demo
unfortunately my demo didn't work out
that as well as i planned initially so
i'm going to walk you through my code
but there's no there's not going to be
any live coding i'm sorry
and then we're going to have q and a uh
so first of all let me tell you a little
bit about qp so
we're an advanced analytics company born
out of formula one but like what does
that mean
um that means that our co-founders used
to do high performance race car
analytics and then one day one beautiful
day they decided
um what about if we apply those
principles into businesses and
that's how qb was born uh the company
was acquired by mckinsey
four years ago so that makes us a
mckinsey unit
no and well particularly i work
for quantum black labs there is the
product engineering part of qb
uh and we we come to black labs is the
the bit of the company that makes the
tools that are used on the advanced
analytics projects
and well that's what pedro came from
i'll talk to you a little bit more
more about kedrain a [ __ ] uh perfect so
let's go it's story time i hope everyone
has coffee and chocolate
because this is gonna take a little bit
of time
uh cool so this is elsa and anna
they're data scientists and their work
they've been working on the same team
they're involved in this new project
analyzing a weather station in singapore
elsa wrote all her code in it using her
laptop
and edupita notebook and everything
works it's great
um she then needs a little bit of input
from anna so she sends her
notebook and a link for the data by
email
uh anna then
picks up everything on friday quite late
it was almost
and she then manages to access the
notebook
but running runs into an issue loading
the data
uh she then tries to see if we can find
out where any
what where elsa is but she finds out
that elsa is already on holidays
and she won't be back until tuesday and
while they can't communicate the project
is on hold
by the end of the day everything is fine
but um
it's a little bit hard to collaborate
and
well everything is kind of time
consuming
um then we cut for two years later
everyone is still in the same company
but now the team
has grown uh
we have um
despite the large qing the projects are
not being completed on time
uh some folders are a little bit messy
and there is a lack of standards
on the project um
due to the volume of scripts and the
volume of notebooks and there is hard
coded
path files everywhere it's a little bit
of a nightmare
um because of that
only one person can work in each project
at the time
there's no consistency in the
development of the development framework
uh there's no workflow that works nicely
with everyone together
and then that makes it very hard as well
to reuse
code that you've written before and it
requires well you're all data scientists
so you all know
that whatever that means you're building
a model it requires you to camp
to keep a mental overview of the project
in your head
at all times and that well if you have
to
if you're doing everything on a month
that's fine but if you have to come back
to it six months later
then the story gets a little bit more
complicated
uh and well this team is getting a
little bit frustrated as well because
the boss
the new boss just joined the company
wants that
project to be um deployed and in
production environment
um so each one of them now have their
own folders
with their own scripts and their
notebooks
now the problem is migrating from
experimentation
um to the to deployment to production
code
would mean another huge project and they
would have to rewrite loads of code
and the risk of breaking things would be
huge
and there's going to be more debugging
and more diff refactoring
um that can bring to this infinite loop
of
experimentation deployment and then
analyzing to see if
what you experiment what you're
experimenting with is actually
um working then further experimentation
and for the
deployment and further analysis um
and well if your business cannot do this
very fast
there's no more business for your
company
then instead of that cyclical process
what uh would be ideal then would be a
stream like a linear workflow instead
where
the goal was to build an effective
system from data consumption
so the ingest data cell over there into
module evaluation in practical terms
this this would mean writing good code
from the start
and making sure that everything is able
to scale easily
as we know scripts on a folder do not
scale easily
and the goal is also to need minimal
modifications from research and
development phase
to get to production um by the end of
the day the last time we spent modifying
the code to fit into production
environment
the best the model will be because there
will be more time invest on that model
on code optimization and documentation
instead of debugging and refactoring
and then here i added a guide
of how to write good code by axis
xkcd uh so basically we have start a
project
and then you can decide if you do things
right or you shouldn't fast
if you go for fast uh you're getting to
this loop here
of they they don't work
that well but you keep going to this
loop and then it became
there is this bundle of scripts and
folders and files
and spaghetti code and then if you don't
go this way if you decide to go
to do things right well things can also
go bad
because the requirements of your project
can change but then
if you use um good practices
you don't necessarily need to throw out
all your codes you can just reuse it
and that is going to bring you to good
code
perfect so that will be the end of the
story
uh to summarize the problems that we've
seen that then
are team collaboration is um team
collaboration is very difficult when
everything is in one
file uh the code research in notebooks
is very hard to scale
um if you're going production it
requires rewriting
rewriting requires a usually implies
that things can break
um there is no reproducibility on your
code
because um since the environments are so
different and you have no
uh you have hardcore file pads
everywhere it's gonna be quite hard
for the same code with the same data to
be running on different machines
and getting the same result also
when you talk about production ready
code the code that is actually going to
be
deployed um everywhere there's not only
the code
there is testing there is logging there
is continue deployment and continue
integration
there's continuous training there's
documentation
there's a bunch of other stuff um
so what would be the solution for this
i think there's a hint over there
um perfect so here we go
uh kedro so cadre is a python
as an open source python framework to
help teams build
data pipelines there robust consistent
scalable deployable and reproducible
that basically means that we use
software engineering principles
to structure your data science machine
learning project
we see that if everyone has a standard
way of working together
the team can then quickly get up to
speed on what the project actually is
so no more mental images of trying to
understand what's going on
um and kedra tries to scale with your
team and your project
uh going from single user to production
environment it can also be used in
academia
um perfect so character is composed by
four or five depending on how you see
the last part of this
um different parts so we have initially
the
product project template uh that is
based on cookie cutter data science
i'm not sure if you're familiar with
cookie cutter data science but it's
basically a boilerplate temp a
boilerplate
code template code uh for your project
and schedule is built using experience
of more than 80 analytics projects
within cookie cutter data science so
we've done a lot of research to bring to
to open source this for you uh then
there is configuration
uh basically we try to remove all
hardcoded variables from
your code uh and we do that by using
the star the data catalog there
is basically a data connector it's a
yellow file
called catalog dariyamo uh that
it's every time that you run your
project the first place where your
project is going to look for
filepads is going to be in that folder
so
whatever you need to do you just need to
make sure that
sorry it's going to make sure that it's
going to look first on that file
so whatever you do you just need to make
sure that all your
data files are in the data catalog
and then that's it there's no more
problem with sharing your data or
sharing your project
um and then nodes and pipelines so nodes
are basically a python function
a pure python function with an output
and an input
um a input goes through the function and
then another push
and then a pipeline is a collection of
these nodes
with a direct relationship
and dependencies in casual you don't
necessarily need to specify what's the
order for your
data pipelines for your nodes to run um
we do that when you declare on the
actual pipelines so i can show you this
in a bit
um then we try we understand
that cattle is quite opinionated uh
so we try and using empathy to tweak
everyone's workflow to make sure that
the code standards are the same
and that scenes can actually work um
effectively together and that's a
sentence from one of
um one of our ketter core engineers that
is
a super cool engineer um
cool so then i'm gonna go now into
the demo part um
so first of all let me just share with
you uh my pie chart
can everyone see my pycharm wonderful
cool so uh first of all
uh let's go into so you're gonna check
the way to generate this
this code here i generated this already
but basically you just need to type
cadre
new um and the documentation kind of
covers that
but um there is a lot of videos online
as well that you can
have a look at how to do that initially
but when you type ketchup when you type
catch on you
um you give a name for your project and
then you're gonna be
this is the template that you're gonna
have on the
that's gonna be generated so basically
here a quick
overview um so the configuration uh
configuration folder
we have here base where the data catalog
resists
the resides and then all your parameters
are also in a yaml file
then local does not get pushed to github
and local is usually where we push
credentials
so if you're if you're using data that
is remotely stored
you can simply uh put your keys
and your access your login
your username your token and your keys
in this file
um and then like you need to figure out
how you're going to do that to share
those credentials with your team
but basically everything's going to be
here so there's again
no trouble with putting with inputting
your data that is
remotely stored on it uh then we have a
data folder
with the layers on the data engineering
convention
if you're interested in knowing a little
bit more about the data engineering
convention
uh you can have a look at our
documentation there's a lot of stuff
there on it
then documentation so
uh we use sphinx for documentation
so basically you can just show all your
documents in here
and then at the end of your project you
can type schedule build docs and
your docs are going to be generated then
a
folder for logs for all the runs uh that
cater run
then we have a lovely folder here called
notebooks uh
that organizes that summarizes and
organizes all your notebooks
in here uh i have my notebook already
here
we come back to this in a second and
then the
source folder so the source photo is
actually the meat of the project
um and this the name this is the name of
the project
i call this test this wasn't supposed to
be the
final project but well um but please do
not confuse this one with the actual
tests
for the pie tests on the project i know
it's a bit confusing i'm sorry about
this um
so inside of the project folder we have
nodes
and we also have pipelines um
the nodes here as you can see it's the
same
name as the file the our jupyter
notebook
so now let's do a little bit of magic
uh so i'm gonna start then
just
opening up our jupiter notebook here
and just one second
i'm a new mac user i'm sorry um
cool so here we go back into notebooks
and then we have our notebook here
uh i prepared this notebook for us
initially so we can just have a look at
real quick so uh first of all
i'm going to run this this is just a
warning suppressor
because i don't really want to keep
having a look at them
then we're going to import uh
the pi library uh requests
then i'm fetching my data source is
actually coming from this
api uh it's a weather channel and
it's a weather api from singapore it's
open
it requires no token to be accessed um
and i'm requesting all the information
from this stage over here
then um i'm getting the request and
assigning to the variable response
then we're trying to then we're
yielding that back um returning that as
a json file that's going to take a
little bit of time because the file is
quite
long but i'm just going to keep going
with you and then we come back to the
data when the data actually returns
uh after we have the data here coming
back
lovely so glad when things work
um so we have here our json file
and as you can see uh there is a
metadata
so it's list of stations uh weather
stations
with ids names and also locations so
latitude and longitude for each one of
them
then if you keep going down you see that
there is their timestamps
for each one their timestamps
on the on the json file
and those time themes have readings for
each one of those stations
they have temperature readings for each
one of the stations
uh so my interest here actually elsa's
interest here
was to fetch the
choose a station and get the timestamps
the list of timestamps and temperatures
for each one of those timestamps
uh so to do that we just go here and you
write a little bit of python
so station then we have an initial
an empty list there's gonna call out
push um
we loop through those items as you can
see here
this are the time stamps and this thing
over here is one of my favorite
tricks of repair of jupiter notebooks
that
you can just fetch the the data in the
cell
before you don't necessarily need to
re-render
um then there's timestamps here so we
put inside of a try catch
um print an error if there is no
temperatures for the
for that specific um timestamp
and then after all we append the values
of the timestamp values and the
temperature values into
this list so if i run this here
so here so it's seven
here because we changed um
and then we're going to print the output
and here we go
we have the list of timestamps and
temperatures
for this station over here
um cool so then let's just generate a
graph
real quick so if we import pandas and
then generate a data frame
we get this lovely graph here um
x x axis with time
uh pretty standard nothing much
then now it comes to magic so how do we
convert this to a casual project
so basically we need to make sure that
um
everything that we're trying to do is
inside of a function so we need to write
a python function
um here if you look at this function
over here i decided to call this
function get temporary data
that takes the date time as a parameter
and if you look at this code
here is the exact same code that we had
here on these three these three cells
just wrapped inside of a function
and the same thing for the true station
this code in here is the exact same code
that is
in here i just decided to take the
station out
and uh put these two parameters in
so now to convert this to a cadre
notebook
you basically go view cell toolbar and
tags
then you add these nodes here
in here and
then we get out of
here we go back to a pie chart
and um basically
if you type quedro jupiter
converge
oh this one is not going to work i i
broke the project right before
but it supposed it's not working for us
right now
but i will show you that it's the exact
same thing so
that is gonna convert that to a notebook
those two cells into
this file here so if you look if you
have a look at it again
the name of the file is the exact same
and we have the functions imported
and the the actual python functions
exactly the way they are there
in here and here
again um then the next photo the next
step then would be to start building
your data pipelines
so um we would go into
our pipeline.pi and in here we're gonna
go
so with the boilerplate coach
this is not here uh so basically what we
say
is for this node there is this function
get temporary data that takes nothing as
an input
and outputs a raw temperature uh
then for a second node we have two
station
that you can see in here uh
and that two station is going to take as
an input
rod temperature and the station id
as parameter and output temperature
and then the third node is not
necessarily going to do anything
but it's going to output a lambda
function it's going to output the actual
temp the plot
that we've seen on the jupyter notebook
so let me the function
plus and the same plot again
and this here is just because we're
using uh matplotlib
um then after that we're going to
catalog that imo
and we determined
which data catalogs we're going to be
using so
for raw temp in here
the output of this here um is going to
be
data one so data one
raw and then there's a json with the
file
i ran this already so you can actually
see that it's here
um
but that wasn't the original plan anyway
uh and then for the temporary plot
uh we have much bloody writer that you
can see
here uh and the output is temporary
plush
so we go here temporary plush that's the
name of the output here
and this is gonna output a graph that is
gonna go to this folder
here this is gonna be the graph and then
finally we have a product parameters
yamu and then in the parameters that i
am
we just type the station id here
um and that's it so we
are ready to roll then the next thing we
do
is let's check if this is working
yay cool so it tells you
kedra tells you the steps so
uh saving data to raw temp
task one uh and then getting your
parameters and putting them into the
temporary data set
the memory data set um fetching your
temperature
completed task two and then completed
task three
um that here generates so if you want to
have a look at your
project now um
there is a thing in casual called
schedule this
casualty is a dag visualization tool
and it works in real time with your code
and basically you you can just have a
look at what's going on
this is a little bit of a small um
project so you don't actually get to
have a chance to see
how selecting the different nodes you
can see here that if you select raw temp
for example
the parameters just disappears which
means that
um if you think there is a mistake on
your raw temp
uh function or let's say your true
station function
uh you're able to see which parts of
your pipelines
actually are affected by that specific
node
which is great when you're trying to
debug things
um so let's go through the code here
again
real quick we have here function get
temporary data
the first function we wrote
that generates the raw temp
that we saw on the data catalog then
that becomes an input for the true
station function
with the parameter station id and then
the output of this function is
temperature readings
um then the lambda function takes the
temperature readings
and plots the graph and outputs the
temporary plus
that is basically um
this graph over here
um yeah cool so now
let's go back how am i on time
you're good on time we have a lot of
time left oh
cool so uh i'm gonna go back then to
the slides so this is the end of the
demo i hope that was
useful and we're going to answer loads
of questions in a bit
um let's go back to slides
now perfect so i want to talk to you a
little bit about the plugins we have
out of the box um we have casual docker
that basically allows you to just it's a
cli command schedule
docker uh schedule build docker i
believe and that's gonna pack your pro
your credit project
and you're able to deploy it using
docker uh there's also casual airflow
um if you want if you like
to use airflow to build your um
pipelines
and this this is also out of the box and
this is our
pipeline visualization tool
then i want to talk a little bit to you
about community
so if you're using or thinking about
using cadro
we have loads of information in our docs
please have a look at our faq there is a
table there with
loads of resources for new users
things that the community is huge then
stack overflow
if you tag your questions uh with kedra
if use hashtag kedro
on stackoverflow we have every week
we have one of our core developers we
call this the wizard of the week
so they're assigned to answer queries on
public channels
about pedro everywhere so um if you have
any questions if you
if you run into an issue you can't do
something just let us know
we're more than happy to help and the
same works for github
uh that's our github address over there
um then
community things so we have
um zipya mandara that is
one of he's not working with us he's a
mckinsey he works
in mckenzie um but he spends pretty much
i would say half of his sunday every
week
doing answering github queries from
users
just because he loves it it's it's quite
interesting to see
he's also the the uh author of cadre
accelerator accelerator
another pedro plugin uh then there is
thames um thames is mr data engineering
one
uh he has a cool youtube channel
with loads of tutorials on kedro
then we have waylon walker there is one
of our super users
um that has he's the author of casual
action
fine kedro stuttos and kettersta
static this there are different
libraries that do different things on
for for cadre projects mostly uh and
he's also the author of
a very cool series of blog posts
teaching
newbies on data science how to like it's
intro to cadro
but it's with a little bit of data
science as well
so you can start in the data science
career already with some good prac so
good software
software engineering best practices then
um
if you would like to contribute uh we
will be hosting a few method sprints
soon so for now we only have data for we
only have dates for
the pycon india that will happen in the
fourth and fifth of october
uh we know the pi data global we're
going to happen in november
but i'm not sure about the dates just
yet we're planning
oktoberfest um
as well uh for the 18th of october
and we have some few mentor sprints as
well around so if you'd like
to contribute just keep an eye on
my uh twitter or yet
twitter as well or even qb twitter and
we'll make sure that we tell you the
dates there
uh then something else cool that we do
so quejo has a playlist
on spotify our designer
decided that yes i decided that was a
good idea to have a cool
lounge um playlist
to figure out how to use schedule to
enjoy your data pipelining
so he built two there's two editions of
casual lounge
and if you want to have a listen to it
just go on that link over there you can
take a picture
and have a listen to it later um
and then well uh just a quick message
from qb
we are hiring so we're looking for data
engineers data scientists machine
learning engineers
and software engineers so if there's
anyone there
there's interested on maybe building the
next schedule
uh just give us a shout send me a
message
and make sure to talk to to talk to
our hr and well
that is pretty much it
i hope everyone had fun
and uh questions now
thank you so much guys for the great
introduction and i can't wait to try out
kedrow on my next project
because i felt these pain points so
often that uh
getter was trying to address and more
than once i kind of
quick and dirty try to build something
like this on my own just so that my
project complexity doesn't explode and
i'm really happy to know a library that
addresses all of this
um thank you um we have actually you're
not the first person that i hear not the
first
user or user to be um
that one that actually thought about
building
a framework like this because well the
the need
is clear it's very necessary um
but yeah we got that first very good do
you know if there's anything else out
there
any uh any other project trying to do
the same or
are you know do you have the head start
and caterer is the way to go
so um we are the only one around to
actually do
what we so to to cover you
from notebook to deployment
because we have testing we have
documentation
we have logging we have versioning um
we allow you to to use there's one of
the
one of the other things that casual has
is this thing called
hoax that is very similar to react hooks
and that allows you to hook um other
libraries external libraries or other
things like cad referral for example
to your project so you do you're not
constrained just
with schedule um other
libraries around that two other
frameworks are on the duties to a lesser
extent
well dagster is one that does it
uh but we are downstairs a little bit
different from us
because we allow we allow etl
um and there is also a few bits and
pieces here there than we do that they
don't
and then i've also got this question a
lot there is a difference between
uh if schedule is a workflow scheduler
and no schedule is not a workflow
scheduler
um it's so
luigi and airflow for example would be
considered uh
workflow schedulers but uh cadro is a
framework
for developing your actual project
and that's what we try to do and then we
cover the other beats around
um around doing that very good point
i knew that luigi and airflow existed
and they were not quite well
i was looking for some great
clarification um
are there any more questions to lies
there's one or two questions came up
in the chat
so someone asked about the the project
template um
it's the comparison
that was one before that was me
and uh so i have used um
ice scaffold with the data science
plug-in in
in the past and you said that you've
done
or at least your team has done a lot of
research on
the various tools out there and you went
with
cookie cutter data science
and so i was wondering
do you do you know the reason for the
decision of cookie cutter data science
over pi scaffold or does anybody else
know any reason to go for one or the
other
hmm that's a great question um
so i know that cookie can data science
was the most widely used so far
in terms of like um helping you
add um data version control on your code
and having a template and adapting that
template to different use cases
i am not sure uh about pi scaffold
so i can't necessarily comment on that
i will gladly have a look um
with our engineers and have a chat with
them about this so if you want to send
me a message or maybe a tweet
a dm on twitch and i'll be more than
glad to
ask them and follow up with that
question for you would that be okay
uh yeah sure thanks thank you
there was one question from maria about
um
what is the difference between what you
did with kedra and just importing the
jupiter notebook into a script and
opening it with pycharm
cool so uh the difference is
you're you have a place to well you have
one file
that you can keep your scripts all in
there as nodes
wrapped around yeah wrapped around the
wrapped around the wrapper um so
becoming nodes and that's the exact
point that i was pointing with
um elisa and elsa and anna
that it's much easier to organize
you don't necessarily need to use that
um
but it's much easier to organize your
data science project
if you have a template that
well separates things and
makes sure that everything has its own
space
and also the thing that actually really
puzzles me when i talk to data
scientists
is um people that i i'm like i'm very
glad to hear that you use scripts
already that you're not
writing everything using only a notebook
uh
that's already great but i'm i'm
always very very interested on hearing
how do you run your data pipelines
like how do you elect the order and how
do you remember
what comes before and what comes later
two months from now two weeks from now
even
or how do you communicate within your
team and if you don't work with
within a team um how do you ask for
people's
opinions and how do you communicate your
project
with them if everything is inside a
folder with
well scripts everywhere and another data
folder
um and a few repeater notebooks with
some graphs
it's it's literally about
best practices to make sure that
everyone works together
in the best possible way
glad to hear thank you maria thank you
for your question
actually if you're more interested in on
having a look at this
um there is a really good article on
medium
i think it's like the five reasons why
you should be using scripts for your
for your uh data science projects and
she runs on like all the great things
about using scripts
uh but then she actually points out
on the on the article that she doesn't
really know
how to scale that and that's the whole
thing that helps you doing scaling
add any more questions from the audience
either in the chat or
just unmute yourself and ask
if not i would like you to tell the open
source story because i heard that
kero is the first open source
project coming out of the mckinsey
company and how did that go
yes yes that is true
so we are the first uh open source
project from mckenzie and we are also
the first open source project from
quantum black
and i am the first developer advocate
for the company
so you see it's a roll of first it's
amazing
um so the reason for open sourcing
initially
um was um well we are a consultancy
company
so we would go into the we were going to
the companies and their
clients and would see what is it that
they need
and we use schedule to develop the
projects
and then when we're leaving they're like
uh
but wait uh how how do i how do i
maintain this now
what do i do what do i do everything in
everything that i'm doing is already
built on this infrastructure using this
infrastructure and
how do i keep how do i maintain this now
and we're like
um okay in that case then we open source
it
going to be open for everyone and then
everyone that knows python can just
use it and tweak it and change it and
make sure if it's their
their own use case um open sourcing edge
i cannot tell you the story of how it
was to actually do it
because our product project manager
would be the perfect person to come here
and tell you everything about that
um but i've heard from her
that open sourcing a project
like this is challenging but it's
it's i mean it's great especially when
you talk about
the support the community gives back
after it that's exactly why i wanted to
point out our community behind casual
because
uh we are quantum black labs um
and with just a little bit of quantum
black but
the community that is behind casual is
its own community um so it's it's
rewarding to see how the contributions
and to see how many different use cases
and
to get people coming back and saying oh
i use schedule for this
and i didn't know what this was possible
to be done um
yeah that's that i think that's the best
part of
open sourcing so far
it's great that you made it work and uh
certainly hope it encourages more
companies to
to go with the flow and use the free
software principle here
to share some technology with the
community
any more questions to lies on kederon
nobody people say they enjoyed the two
talks
let me thank you again and that we're at
the end of our two talks camila do you
want
i need just our final words thank you so
much
to chuck to lies uh for being with us
we see again in november and ways to
keep in touch so you can follow us on
twitter we also have our linkedin group
so pi data homework
both channels and again we are really
looking for
speakers if you're working on cool stuff
just reach out to us
first time by data speakers
underrepresented groups
anyone else anyone welcome so just reach
out to us and we are very happy to see
you again in november thank you so much
bye bye